hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game uh from the tc ec9 super
final between stalkfish 8 and houdini 5
and uh it's uh well it's quite a quite a
crazy one
as usual the super final consists of 100
games
they each play the same opening with the
both the black and the white pieces and
then
uh they they switch so first uh it's
like uh
we go for the knight of sicilian then
stockfish has the white piece in the
knight of sicilian or rather in the line
of the knight or sicilian and then they
switch then houdini 5 has the white
pieces in the same line
then they go through other lines through
other openings and so on when they cover
100 games whoever wins the most is the
winner
and this is a very interesting game
comes as a suggestion from
gen z on twitter so thank you for that
very uh
very uh much appreciated uh so let's
just check it out and it's always
dangerous to watch these engine games i
remember when um
when alpha zero first uh came into
existence and we got uh got a glimpse of
alpha zeros games and we were you know
watching them enjoying them even trying
to to maybe study them
and then when there were no more alpha
zero games to cover it was like
we had to go cold turkey and then human
games they appeared like
i mean what's this it's like going from
let's say 8k graphics to like 360p
graphic
graphics so not something uh you you
should do on a regular basis so
uh that's why we don't show engine games
all that much but still when a nice one
such as this one appears that we will
definitely check it out
so uh the engines are pre-arranged uh
we're not gonna dwell too long on the
openings so here we have e4 by stockfish
uh c5 knight to f3 we have d6 so a nice
sicilian defense we have d4
captures captures and now knight to f6
we have knight to c3
and of course a6 uh sorry not a6 not the
knight or
we have g6 the dragon sicilian we have
bishop to e3
and now bishop to g7 and now f3 uh
the beginning of the yugoslav attack
against the dragon sicilian
and this is something if you've uh uh
heard it for example
bobby fischer often claimed that the the
dragon is just
bad uh for for black because all white
has to do
is do go for this set up a bishop e3
queen d2 start pushing those spawns g4
h4 h5 bust open the position
and win the game and uh it's been sort
of had that uh kind of a rapid
reputation over the years and while it
did come back
uh from time to time it's really hard to
say now it's
you know if you have a nice preparation
then maybe you can surprise someone
but if you if you don't know what you're
doing it's very very dangerous to play
uh so here we have castles and now queen
to d2 preparing this bishop to h6 the
uh trade of the dark square bishops we
have knight to c6 and now
uh knights knight to c6 and now bishop
to c4
so everything been playing before this
is the main line of the dragon bishop to
d7
and queen side castles now and the rook
the c8 black goes for the standard setup
he wants to play 95
put pressure on the bishop then bring
the knight to c4 attack the dark square
bishop and the queen
and so on so this is all very uh
standard stuff with bishop to b3 and
knight e5 so all been played before
there are thousands of games in the
database with this exact same idea
uh h4 white starts what uh fischer uh
was
was talking about h4 g4 h5
so knight the c4 now if white doesn't
capture then we're gonna eliminate
white's dark square bishop and this is
just a beautiful piece so we would be
very happy to eliminate
that one so bishop captures we much
rather give up the light square bishop
we have rook captures and the
h5 now so a nice spawn sacrifice to get
things started
uh knight captures and now g4 instead of
g4
you might con consider something like
rook captures on h5 and if you're
playing a bullet or a blitz game
you probably would go for this but here
as this is uh
well a very very serious game between
two engines uh we have g4
pushing back the knight knight f6 and
now a nice prophylactic
king to b1 uh and rook to e8
and here b3 chasing away the rook and
here the rogue goes back to c8 in the
other game where the colors were
reversed
uh where houdini had the white pieces
stock which retreated to c7 not the c8
but
that game uh well we're going to discuss
that game after we check out this one
so rook back to c8 and now knight to d5
very very uh good square for the night
so of course black wants to eliminate
this knight
knight captures e captures and now we
reach the position that was already
reached uh and it was uh reached in
germany
under uh under 14 championship in 2003
uh between felix klein and jan sol and
in that game the bishop to e5 was played
however for this game
uh we have e5 and it is only now as of
move 19 that we have a completely new
game
so who would think that in 2003 those
two those two gentlemen were playing
such a such a
top tier game and who i always imagined
that you know some
incredibly strong players were checking
out the game watching their moves and
they were like and it's
you know it's it's not all that
impressive uh but okay
uh e5 uh and here white of course
captures alpha song so
d captures an e6 f captures an e6 and
now
uh queen to h2 and black doesn't really
have
any defense against this the h7 pawn is
under attack the d6 pawn is under attack
and this is what they probably meant or
rather what bobby meant when he said it
was too easy to attack black
very often it will be difficult for
black to prevent something like this
uh why did just sacrifice the white one
pawn and he already has a very nice
attack
so queen to f6 uh creating some counter
play if now the knight
for example moves then queen to b2 will
be checkmate
but now comes not queen captures an h7
right away and it's very interesting i
mean
anyone would pretty much pre-move this
but stockfish first improves the
position with a4
uh problem is uh after you capturing
king f7 you don't really have a good
continuation if g5 yes you push back the
queen
queen e5 now let's say rook h6 goes
after this pawn
but now queen captures on e3 and after
rook captures on g6 going after the
bishop rook g8
and now we get this position where white
can continue with f4
and so on uh the pawn cannot be captured
because rook f6
check wins the queen the bishop of
course is pinned so
while all this is possible stockfish
says no that i mean there's
no rush we're just gonna play a4 first
so once all of this
has been played then i will already have
played a4
that's how that's how engines play so
here b6
and only now queen captures on h7 with
check king f7 and now we go into the
setup that we've discussed g5 queen to
e5 and now
rook to h6 putting pressure on g6 giving
up the dark square bishop
so queen captures on e3 and now rook
captures on g6 rook the g8 and now the
move we've discussed and that is f4
uh so now uh of course this cannot be
captured if you captured rook f6
check like we've said wins the queen so
instead we have
d5 by black and now what do you play
here
well white just uh starts uh marching
forward we have
f5 e captures on f5 and
now uh knight captures on f5 and now
there's a triple attack on the bishop
here
and it's very it's a very tricky
position not a lot of moves are
rather there's only one move that
doesn't lose this position for black
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this idea for houdini while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not playing bishop captures on f5 and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
yes it's uh we're going to do it in slow
motion uh queen
captures on b3 that's that's the good
stuff
but just in case you're wondering why
not bishop captures an f5 well because
if bishop captures
then we go into this rook captures and
g7 with check
rook captures and queen captures bishop
with check and we also pick up this rook
once the king moves we're just gonna
eliminate the rook and then let's say
whatever black plays uh yes the material
is equal but
the white king is nicely protected here
nothing you can do to pretty much harass
it
and the black king is uh wide open here
so it's gonna be very easy to attack uh
and this is a completely winning for
white
so we return to the slow motion queen
captures on b3
and now what do you play you are in
check and you only have one move
if if you move the king then it is just
checkmate
so you have to capture the queen so uh c
captures on b3
and then now comes bishop captures an f5
with
check king the a2 and now not rushing
into bishop captures on g6 because if
you do this then rook to f1 check
the king has to move and then white
starts playing and you really don't want
to lose
uh either of the two bishops because
they're just amazing they're
attacking the the white king here and
you do not want to trade
either of them so after king 282 we have
rooked the c2 with
check king to a3 and only now bishop
captures and g6
but now it's a bit different because now
rook to f1 check
king the e7 and now uh you don't really
have the option of uh capturing this guy
uh because if you capture it then just
bishop to b2 picks up the queen
so you have to capture the rook it kind
of sounds normally of course we're going
to capture the rook but
it's the bishop pair i mean look how
look how strong this bishop perry is so
maybe grabbing the light square bishop
would be better for white however
queen captures and g8 is a must you
cannot touch the bishop
and now bishop to b to check we have
king to b4 and now bishop the c3 check
and now if uh stockfish 1 and stockfish
could repeat this for example
just go back and forth but stockfish
wants to win
stockish goes king b5 and now bishop to
d3 with
check we will win the the lights not the
the light square but the white rook so
king to c6 and now
bishop to e5 uh with uh with the
discovered to check from the rook we
have king to b7
and now rook the c7 with checks so the
king has to go further up the board
uh we have king to a8 not of course in
front of the bishop that would just be
weird
so bishop captures on f1 we grab the
rook
and now queen captures on d5 so a
stockroot did not want to draw stock
which still feels confident that
that uh he's gonna be able to win this
so bishop back to g7
and now king to b8 pushing back the rook
rook to d7
attacking the queen and queenie for
check now so
if uh the queen can somehow connect the
check to pick off one of these
bishops or the rook then of course the
position will be winning uh but that's
easier said than done
king of f8 and now queen to f5 check yes
you've
you've accomplished this but rook to f7
you will not be winning that bishop
queen t8 check king to e7 now queen to
c7 check king e6 and queen to c6 check
king f5 and now queen to d5 with
check and now what do you play here
problem is if you go king to g6 then
white just wins very easily
queen e6 check and you don't really have
a good move here you have to move the
king
then just g6 check and that's it you you
just fall apart here it just captures
the rook
and it's game over so instead after this
queen to d5 check we have bishop
blocking with check uh king a8
and now well you don't have bishop to g2
unfortunately
but you do have rook to f8 to check king
captures on a7
and now bishop to e2 uh we have b4
white doesn't really have a way of
winning any of the pieces
uh so white will now try to eliminate
this pawn and then push the two pass
pawns to victory so bishop to h5 trying
to kick away the queen with bishop to f7
and now king captures on b6 and now we
have this position uh two bishops in a
rook against the queen
and three past pawns so bishop to f7
kicks away the queen queen f3 checked
and now bishop
for blocking we have queen to c6 uh and
now rook to b8 with check king a7
and now king captures on g5 so
eliminating one of white's pass pawns
uh queen to d7 now uh attacking the the
bishop here
and bishop back to h5 uh we have b5
uh black king needs to be very very
careful because if those bishops uh
somehow get uh you know get angry it
could be
there could be game over so here rook to
e8
uh just uh you know getting the rook to
to a safer square
we have b6 and now bishop to e3
uh so okay now the pawn cannot move we
have queen to d5 with
check king to h4 and now a5 the other
pawn is also marching up the board
rookie seven check king to a8 and now
rook to e8 with
check king b7 now you have to get out of
checks if you want to uh
do anything more than then draw the game
so rook the e7 would
check king to c8 and now bishop to g4
with check king back to b8 and then out
bishop to f4 check we have king to a8
and now comes king to g3 uh you don't
really gain anything by this checking to
a7
and then you just uh have to worry about
those pawns so king to g3
now with the idea that if white pushes
for example b7 then uh you run
into trouble because then rook the e8
check and you're in a lot of problems
b8 queen now we're gonna capture this
just uh
and you really don't have anything and
you also have to worry about ideas like
bishop f3 then you lose the queen
and so on so instead after king g3 we
have queen to g8
and now okay the bishop is pin so maybe
you can now push the pawn
but now comes rook to e5 we have a6
now comes rook to e6 attacking this pawn
here
king to b7 now ready to push the a pawn
and now bishop to e3 going after this b6
pawn
uh here we have a7 uh rook captures on
b6 with
check king to c7 and rook to a6
now uh we have a8 queen getting that
queen finally into the game
and now comes uh bishop to f4
with check king to b7 and now you really
don't have
any other options you have to capture
rook captures and now we have king
captures
and it was in this position that uh
houdini
five resigned the game as there seems to
be nothing more you can do here
which is actually really weird because
this is a table based draw
or rather it's not a draw it's a force
to win for white from this position
uh in 72 moves but if you know it takes
more than 50 moves to to win uh then uh
it's uh it's a draw by by a 50 move rule
so i don't know if
in this uh match between stockfish and
houdini the 50 move rule applies
uh because this game actually ended by
uh houdini resigning which uh which
i believe in these engine games happens
when both engines
agree that the evaluation is over 10 for
uh for either of them but this is in
human terms this
is a draw so it would take 70 moves
72 moves with perfect fl play from white
and of course black to
actually win this position which which
is kind of a draw
so i don't know why this was why this
was attributed as a win
for stockfish but it was uh so
really really impressive stuff this game
really really had it all
uh from the from the beginning to to
that
crazy crazy game and then the then this
queen captures on b3 action and then all
of that i mean it was just
pretty pretty crazy it's hard to imagine
that we we will see
any humans playing playing such a game
but you never know
uh it's not not uncommon for it to
happen from time to time
uh but yeah uh like i said fischer said
just push those h4g for
h5 and you're gonna win the game easily
but here uh
houdini prevailed and was able to hold
this to a draw or not i have no idea
what happened here
uh but yeah in the end stockfish won the
super final with a score of 54 and a
half to 45 and half so stockfish eight
is the is the uh
tcec uh season nine uh champion
so uh awesome stuff from uh from
stockfish we'll see what happens in the
next season as you know these things uh
tend to
tend to change uh so that's the game i
hope you guys enjoyed it uh
i would like to thank uh lucien uh
lucinda time ciao antonio francesco
dandecar
uh tom deralau richard lawrence and it
frongos.com for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage uh of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh the candidates
tournament is also
uh about to resume so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day